hi everybody that's louder than I
thought I'm sorry hi everybody
yeah take some adjusting but I yeah
check one check check
good good all right I figure so uh big
news from yesterday on the with PC
gaming show was that yesterday I'm yeah
oh I don't don't ask me huh was it
yesterday day before a different foreign
a get for yesterday yep yeah yeah war of
the chosen X come to its biggest
expansion to date right yeah it's big
it's very very big it's um it's I'm
trying to think of another word than big
right now it's huge it's met massive
gigantic its bursting it has a bad
that's not good girthy yeah oh my god
what ah yeah yes comprehensive [ __ ]
better thank you yeah I don't want to
sound like too much of a kiss-ass but
XCOM 2 is one of my favorite game yes
yeah I wish uh no that's ok
continue ah it's going every lobby is
genius no but uh yeah I'm excited for
this and actually I missed it because we
were watching something else like during
the PC game show I was hosting something
upstairs and then I got off and I came
down I got the stage and then I came
down to catch up on it it looks really
great um but it looks huge because the
last I think the biggest one for 2 so
far was Shen's last gift right yeah we
had a couple of DLCs and then this one
is it's not you know it's it's an
expansion it's huge you know we have a
lot of ton of new enemies we have three
new soldier classes we've got all kinds
of toys for the player to engage with
it's just really really big tons of
systems like I lost my voice in the
first day because I was trying to
explain the whole thing to people and
then my spelling right now I have to
like hit high points and just hope
people trust that it's it's really
really big yeah um would it be fair to
compare it to a the evil within Wow no
[ __ ] all right
not at all it's experimental
oh my god enemy within retreat which
pretty much they would not answer long
week
oh yeah but yeah you're right enemy
offense so yeah it's it's like it's it's
much much bigger even than enemy within
it it's huge it's huge um and so you
know we have these these shows and these
handsome handsome aliens there and so
they're like these in there
huh she's lovely they're these that
they're kind of like the ultimate enemy
of X common so they're like the player
in the sense that the player is going to
fight them multiple times of course the
game and every time they do the chosen
are going to get stronger they're going
to gain they procedurally gain new
strengths and new weaknesses and so
maybe one time you come in to fight the
assassin you think you know she's going
to work but instead now she's completely
immune to melee and you're like okay I
just lost my ability to attack her that
way and so it just forces the player to
sort of rethink things every time they
face them that's awesome it reminds me a
little bit of the Nemesis system sort of
maybe not as like deeps Nemesis system
order kind of befores yes yeah I mean
that was definitely the inspiration
absolutely um you know we thought
certainly that the ability to have those
procedural strengths and our characters
are more fixed but having we've never
had enemies with actual personality
before and so that's one of the big
things we wanted to do here was add a
lot of characters with personality and
so they always play procedurally it's
still very much XCOM but they all
personnel as they'll talk to you when
you're fighting them about how you did
against them last time how the other
chosen are doing big things you've done
throughout the game and then they'll
talk to you outside of combat as well
and it's the same thing with the
factions these are the new sort of new
resistance movements that player can
integrate with they have leaders and
those leaders are characters and they'll
be talking to you about things that are
going as well so it's very lively and
even to the point where we have on your
on the dropship back from missions you
know you'll hear like the radio from the
Advent the government and they'll be
trying to spin what you just did I know
for them look like I know nobody worried
it was no big deal nobody got hurt
just a gas explosion or something and
then in the base when you go into the
bar
we actually have Jake Busey on people
you know Jake Busey is and he's Gary
Busey's amazing son and he's our radio
resistance DJ and so he'll be in there
and he's like spinning thing for the
resistance so there's just a lot of
voices and a lot of characters that are
they all respond to the things that
you're doing and so it really feels like
okay this is a real resistance movement
people are responding to it it feels
like a live world you go more into the
like how you build the relationships
with the
distance factions because like in the
trailer it says like problem is that
they all hate each other that's wrong
like you're kind of seems like it's
almost like city-state relationships to
talk about civilization yeah yeah you
you have to win them over and so yeah
they have very different philosophies
all these different factions have
different philosophies and you need to
win them over and the way you do that is
that each faction is kind of paired off
against one of these chosen and so to
win over the factions you kinda have to
go after the chosen that they don't like
and then eventually you can recruit
their soldiers which are very very
powerful units you can have more control
over their faction you can start telling
them what to do and so it's a really
it's another really in-depth system
that's totally new for people who get
really geeky about it like me can you go
a little more in-depth on the three oh
yes I can you need that's like kinda I'm
never afraid to go geeky yeah you know
that's it that's what I do um yeah so
you've got one faction it's they're
called the Reapers and they are stealth
marksmen and they're saboteurs so they
can attack yeah there you go there's a
reaper so um so they can attack from
concealment and there's always a chance
that they won't be conceived then will
be revealed every time you attack you'll
actually see like a meter rolling and be
like oh you stayed concealed okay and so
it's always this big trade-off of do I
really want to you know they're a great
Scout unit but they're also really
deadly so you kind of trade that off and
then there's a skirmisher which is there
defectors from the alien army that
actually join XCOM and so they're
they're half alien half soldier hybrids
and they're skirmisher look at the nails
see you can tell with a house that's not
human it's not human but it needs to get
that touched up
but yeah so they they're really powerful
they take a lot of actions every turn
and so they get an extra action if
somebody attacks them they even have an
ability called battle Lord which if they
trigger it then every time an AI unit
takes an action thus kirmser gets an axe
how cool they can take like ten actions
in one single turn they're crazy and
then the final group is called the
Templars
and they're this melee only class and
they have these big psionic blades there
we go there's the Templars and they're
cool because they build up power every
time they attack they build up power and
then they can unleash it with their
really powerful ability so there's this
trade-off of building up how
and then wanting to keep it because it
makes their attacks more deadly or you
can unleash it in these really big
powerful attacks well for me I'm an
ex-con newbie I'm such a baby
welcome I don't know any I don't know
much about it I do love strategy though
this don't thing I can jump into or
should I start off on just face game no
no you can definitely jump into this
because this integrates completely with
the base game I mean what we've done is
we've added a bunch of new narrative
we've added all this stuff but it
actually sits on top and integrates into
the base game and so you know we've got
a new intro cinematic we've got a new
finale we got all the cinematic stuff
that adds in we got all this gameplay
stuff that ends in but yeah you can just
jump right in and and get going okay cuz
I think Michael want me to play this I
want to check it out yeah for sure that
I can yeah straight into it I'll do it
so got it every day yeah my god I'm not
joking we need an ex-con jar where he
puts a dollar in every time he brings it
up yeah I did not tell them to say this
I promise
yeah I'm curious
so someone myself who's played a lot and
I want to go into like mods if you don't
mind a little bit outside of the dlc
because I've been playing the long war
pretty regular long war too regularly I
have since it came out yeah you are for
real yeah I'm a masochist I look I can't
make it past a mission and that yeah I'm
just like oh this is for real yeah well
I haven't beaten it yeah whatever
running a lot of it I don't you know
like you only beat XCOM XCOM too broad a
lot but I'm curious what um the chosen
war is gonna do to like the overall flow
of XCOM - right like what does it mean
for like you know you said you go to the
bar and you've got a new character there
that's kind of like doing the propaganda
stuff on both sides Advent and
resistance you know and I'm curious what
like if I'm someone who's played a lot
of X come - yeah chose more when I jump
into it outside of these like these
three factions and you know like all the
added layers with these bosses what is
gonna be like for the overall like
identity of it it's very it's very
different I mean so we have all these
small systems that change that we've
changed research we change so your
soldiers now they get fatigued and so if
they go on multiple missions even if
they're not wounded they're going to get
tired and what that means is that you're
going to start rotating a lot more
soldiers through the game is much longer
because of all this extra content one of
the cool things is that your soldiers
can now
negative traits which are like
personality quirks okay and so they get
really wounded you know one of the
funnier ones is the obsessive and that
means that that soldier if they're
running around and the gun isn't fully
loaded instead of doing what you tell
them to do they'll instead they'll
reload and so it sounds like me right so
you have that you have this big tactic
you want to pull off maybe like move
over here and then move up there then be
like oh my guns not loading they'll
reload and you're like ah crap you know
and so it creates these these
personality quirks with your soldiers
and so there's a lot of these little
elements that just really change the way
that the game used to work and it's it's
a longer game you have a lot more
soldiers you have these heroes they're
all these new strategy systems
interacting with the factions there's a
lot of fun stuff like there's a daily
there's a like a propaganda mode so
every time you win a mission what it's
going to do is take your soldiers and
it's going to put them together and pose
them in a bunch of different poses and
generate like a motto for this squad and
then it'll put filters over it and you
can you can adjust everything you can
type in what texts you want you can
rotate your soldiers give them from a
bunch of different poses and so you sort
of take this like group selfie after the
mission take a picture and then that
poster starts appearing throughout the
world on the sides of buildings and and
so there's there's just on the fun side
of things there's a challenge mode so
you can jump in and play a sort of like
challenge that it's you got 30 minutes
you got one time to beat it and then
you're ranked against everybody else in
the world and there's these really
difficult challenge so if you just want
to play a little bit of XCOM so yeah
there's just there's just tons and tons
of stuff yeah that's awesome because
it's kind of hard to explain to people
outside of XCOM that there actually is a
little despite the fact that it's like
this pretty hardcore strategy title
there's a lot of personality to it like
I remember some of my favorite like
snipers and grenadiers 'he's from XCOM
to more than I do in like narrative
games yeah and I like this stuff because
I feel like it'll increase my connection
to this world into these characters
that's right I don't know if that's the
aim for that that's absolutely the aim
there's two sides of story it's a story
that you know the dictated like
narrative cinematic story and we
certainly have added to that but really
the stuff that sticks reviews players is
your own moments and being able to share
those and so we have something called
soldier bonds which leans into that the
idea is that soldiers form relationships
with each other
and so now soldiers have compatibility
with other soldiers you take them on
missions and you'll find out hey these
two are really compatible and if they go
on multiple missions together they'll
form a bond and that means when they go
on missions together they get a bunch of
free abilities that are all about their
bond and so it just sort of creates a
new story like oh these two guys they
love each other and these two over here
they're they bond it together and
they're really powerful when they're
together so it sort of feeds in that you
have like the player driven story that
inspired by Fire Emblem yeah yeah yeah I
mean you you will not be able to bring
your kids back from the future I we have
I don't we don't yet have that
technology
oh but yeah I mean I always I always
loved that about firing them it just
makes sense you know in your head you're
already forming these relationships
between characters and so you know just
sort of was a natural thing to do
yeah yeah and I'm curious actually
speaking of like long war - have you
been talking to the team that did that
and like how that's gonna affect or how
the DLC might affect that I haven't I
haven't talked to those guys yeah oh
that's that's on my list of things but
yeah I didn't want I was talking to pee
before the show about like like mods and
how you can go about creating them and
obviously the leak the long war is
probably the one that arose out of the
most and that's the most you know the
famous one that came out and I played a
lot I played like long war - a lot and
you've always been really vocal that you
love supporting modding community talk
about I guess like in broad terms what
the Monty community has done for XCOM -
specifically I mean it's amazing so I
think that it's this idea and there are
some Studios like this and where you
when you realize that if I'm a creative
director my team we're not the owners of
the game or the game experience like it
is especially once you have a number
after your name in the in the game that
means that the only reason you exist is
because there's an audience the audience
owns the game I'm not going to go off
and make something that the audience
doesn't like you know they're they're
more owners of the game than and then
any of us are and mods are the ultimate
extension of that where members of your
audience are actually creating content
and they can serve people may have I
want this specific thing like long war
we exhales not hard enough we want it
even more
hard we want it more complex and so to
allow your audience to sort of be part
of the
creative process like it's a gift
because we can't make that much content
nobody can and you can cater to very
specific parts of your audience you can
create all this content you can get
direct feedback from people it's it's
amazing so I'm so glad that it's worked
out like the modding is it's a very big
part of what XCOM is yeah I think some
of my favourite mods are kind of minor
as well like having the halo weapons in
the game right that's really good yeah
or like Star Wars cuff uh Bob Ross mod
is pretty strong oh oh it is amazing
explain this to me what is amazing it's
you get you have Bob Ross you have the
model it's it's Bob Ross he's got his
hair and then voice lines from Barber
and like actual lines from Bob Ross oh
he'll be like oh isn't that a pretty
little and he'll be like yes I'm gonna
be like that's a beautiful thing I do
like it's just amazing and so in those
are moments where like obviously
probably for legal reasons I could have
nothing to do with that but um but you
watch that and you're just like I've got
to try that I've got to play that so
yeah it's amazing and so there's the
funny mods there's a serious mods
there's the purely cosmetic mods it's
just really amazing stuff yeah and if
you don't mind me saying I think there
are mods that make your game better
maybe things yeah oh my god the evac all
it's Lawren think that was like a minor
one so when you're trying to like evac
troops from a dropship you used to have
to uh yeah you they were not kidding you
are hardcore yeah okay yeah no you used
to have to like go clean one evac can be
take even rappel up to it but then of
course there's evac also they would all
just go through once you're in the zone
of the dropship but like what's it like
seeing modders like like I said it
sounds like you're open to the idea that
say boys you're shorter yeah we don't
think that we can't tell people we've
made the perfect game every time we make
it we don't believe that and so it's
nice again mining is great because if
all of a sudden there's this hey the
audience really doesn't like this so
they think this would make it better
people can use our tools go out there be
like we made it for you and then we can
play and be like that's amazing like we
integrate stuff from mods like we look
at and we improve on it now since you're
so hardcore I will tell you we now have
the ability to as you're moving your
mouth is you moving the cursor around if
you hold down the Alt key it will show
you a preview of like what are the
target
options at that location Oh second so
that's super nice really and that was
inspired by some mods pushed what we did
further and we said okay we'll go even
further than that and it just it's a
great symbiotic relationship yeah I've
got people I've got friends who play
XCOM - and it's a question I want to ask
you is do does the like vast amount of
mods in the war in the XCOM - community
diminish the the impact of like pay DLC
when you can play these mods for free I
don't think so I mean I think that what
mods do is that keep people engaged and
they change it up and they keep it fresh
for people and then we can come along
and do things that other people can you
know we can create certain types of
content certain types of gameplay that
you know we hope we can add value that
others can't but for us we see the mods
is it's a great way of saying like okay
the community gets all this new content
that they can engage with and then we
can come in that gives us a time you
know it took us a while to make this
product it took so long to make
something this big it took us our entire
team it took us a long time and thank
God for mods that can keep people
excited and playing and then we can come
in later and say alright now we have
this massive thing that you know modders
can't do and then we release it to
people and I think everybody gets
re-energized and then people are just
going to go and mod the expansion pack
yeah um and then I think we did an
interview with you recently if I'm not
mistaken or like a couple months ago we
asked you like at a certain point does
the game stop becoming the developers
and almost become fans like how do you
balance implementing fan feedback with
like the authorial intent on your side
yeah and that's the balance is that even
if your audience they're not designers
but they are the owners in my opinion
their values are more important than
mine I'm not gonna I'm not going to
force try to force my values on players
because if I do that then I won't be in
this job very long so I listen to what
they say and I say okay I'm the designer
I should have the tools to implement
what they want you know you know so they
tell me I don't like this or this parts
crater we wish we had more of that well
then it's my job to say okay my job my
training should allow me to say like I
know how to implement that and so that's
what that's what's led to a lot of the
things in the expansion pack is saying
like okay we've heard what people love
about ex-con
- what they want what they want improved
and so let's go out there make something
massive it sort of delivers on that if
enough people got in your ear is there
ever a chance we could see XCOM come to
Nintendo switch um yeah as a player I
would love that I can say with all
honesty I have not had that conversation
yet but yeah I definitely seen the
Vallon that for sure
Knights we got Mario and rabbits ask you
about that I know but I just you know I
see if I see an opportunity for
something that would work great with a
touch screen in some respects absolutely
absolutely
know that that's absolutely true I mean
we've certainly had success on touch
screens with um enemy Unknown so yeah
what do you think of Mario + rabbits
battling them I mean I could I wish I
wish somebody had a camera on me as I
was watching press conference I was like
I was like oh cool yeah and that was
like what say well what is that was like
what are they doing and then there's
like some point where I think some guy
was like and as you see a Luigi how
stick in half Guevara and I was like
what world am i in i seriously have had
a stroke um so it's a man I mean it is
amazing to me it's really really cool I
think what they've done is really cool I
mean it like just seeing it is very
exciting I love the look of it and it
for me it's fun I cannot play XCOM with
my daughter's in fact so I have three
daughters seven four and one and so the
other day when I was on the PC gaming
show my wife was like hey let's watch
daddy on it on the show and I forgot to
tell like the trailer is going to be on
before I come on and it's just all these
scary like you know my daughter's like
oh geez I don't let them watch XCOM and
so I see this and I'm like hey there's
something that's turn-based its tactical
it's not X comments they're completely
new thing but there are similarities
there and I'm like I can actually like
play something and I could be like hey
daddy does something kind of like this
you know and so I could have that
experience with them so for me it's
awesome do you see the fact that maybe
since it was on Nintendo sorry Ubisoft
stage but Nintendo's involved the fact
that like now Mario is getting into this
kind of genre like sub-genre of strategy
ya know Fire Emblem is another
comparison yeah do you see this as a
promising kind of maybe
spark for other teams to make games like
this unquestionably I mean we all we all
build off of each other you know
everything every time I play a game you
know everything I do I'm sitting there
going like how can I use this how can I
use this and so it's great I mean is is
going to bring more fans to a tactical
gameplay and so yeah I mean yeah it's
it's so awesome to see it's so awesome
to say so yeah I think it's for me it's
exciting I think it's it's validating
when you make you know turn-based
tactics to see some other Studios trying
it out and adding their own spin on
things so it's it's really exciting did
you see anything else from whether it
was Nintendo Ubisoft for anything that
excited you you get to watch the press
conferences yeah
yeah I mean Battlefront like the
single-player portion of it like you
know like that's really really exciting
for me I'm a super Star Wars nerd um
yeah anthem I think anthem anthem by or
does anything that's the kind of studio
that I'll be like okay I will definitely
play that you know I just EVC like the
Bioware logo and I'm like yeah alright
I'll buy that I'll play that um so yeah
I mean I think those were two that I was
super excited about last night looks
pretty crazy um looked really cool so
yeah I mean I love I love e3 I mean I'm
I'm a gamer I love you three I'm not
cynical about it like I get so excited
seeing what people are making like it's
just as exciting yeah more personal side
uh going back to XCOM as you can imagine
after I've been talking about it I
actually know a deal like a decent deal
about how XCOM in 2012 became a thing
you know not easy no what is it like now
that X calms down the world XCOM 2 and
you're just like pushing out dlc now
those expansions like Nintendo Ubisoft
we're kind of getting into that kind of
game what does it feel like to go from
the struggle that was to bring XCOM 2012
to life to now I mean it's very
different I mean it's very different and
I'm very very grateful I mean because
the thing to remember is that what we do
it's it's very like you know what did
you do last I mean we all know like your
your first bad games probably your last
one and so I just sort of keep that
present and I think our team we stay
hungry and we get excited by what other
people are doing and all of us we went
through that and it was hard and then we
got to a point like this
but we still remember like we just need
to worry about like making sure we're
always making a good game and that's
what always comes down to you always
going to make a good game so yeah it's
it but it is rewarding it's it's super
wording to look around and see more
turn-based tactical games and seeing
that becoming a bigger deal like that's
it's pretty cool do you get the chance
to play any fire emblems much of them oh
yeah I mean yeah and and I think that
that's really inspiring I mean they do
completely different things to do they
do damage types they do they did the
relationship stuff and so yeah I mean
you get you feed off of those kinds of
games you feed off of I'm playing
persona right now
like in my hotel room well I brought my
ps4 and it was like hey you gonna party
that I'm like are you kidding me like
yeah I have three young kids some hearts
to steal I see oh [ __ ] he is four so I
wake up in the morning I play persona I
go to bed at night playing persona like
I'm like just you know it that to me is
like the dream of e3 it's not the
parties it's like being in a hotel room
just playing video games but uh where
are you in the game without spoiling too
very early I'm very er I'm still
attacking the first castle so happy -
yeah there's a guy in the pink underwear
and the robot I'm having a hard time
parsing uh what I'm seeing step ups and
some of the enemies get pretty graphic
yeah later on if you haven't seen them
yet I think you know what I'm talking
about if you have but I don't think I
don't think I mean I've seen some
strange once where I'm like I'm not sure
what I'm yeah I'm looking at there but
yeah that's that's a joy that's part of
the joy of it you're just like wow this
is yeah yep so you are like you know it
for access itself between civilization
the recent Civilization 6 and XCOM 2 and
going back in your development history
you've been very I think it's fair to
say focused on like PC development but
no XCOM has come to consoles yeah last
generation with XCOM and enemy within
not evil within but within what's also
on it so though so I guess I'm lying and
um but then of course now it's on ps4
Xbox one X cotton XCOM - yeah um what do
you think of like Xbox 1x all this stuff
that's coming out with this what do you
think of this console shift toward
almost like PC cycles it's pretty
interesting yeah I mean I think the the
basically they now have to make the case
of like why why I'm upgrading and it's
easy for me
because you know I'm like a hardware
junkie you know something like yeah that
sounds amazing like for KI that means
that I have to buy that and then I have
to buy a 4k TV because I have to
obviously I it's research for work so
yeah for me it's exciting I love I love
backwards-compatibility because there's
still games that I still enjoy you know
and so it's really cool if they can if
they continue that then that for me is
really exciting um yeah I mean it's it's
it's them responding to the market it's
in being smart you know and so yeah I
think it's great does it change how you
think at all about like development on
your end I don't everybody we talked to
says like you know like making it for
the to be supported on the Xbox one X is
actually pretty simple because it
actually like can benefit like working
for the s and the Xbox one etc and
that's rise for pro can also benefit the
slim version right on what is it does it
change how you think I mean I think is
that you you get excited at the
possibilities especially if you make
cross-platform so if you're making a PC
title where you you have to take
advantage of these wide ranges of
hardware and some pretty extreme
hardware you'll always worry about like
the minimum spec is what you worry about
those so you know you got to make it
work on Xbox one and just ps4 and then
you look at you know the pro you look at
the X and you say like what extra can we
do and for us it's exciting because we
make PC games as well we already can
take advantage of something better
hardware yeah I just to go back to X
come toward the end we have another
guest coming on soonish but I do want to
go back before we leave um future of
ex-con right like I said it took a while
for you to get XCOM to be a reality
backup 12 it's like a decade-long
probable thing from you know like a cult
classic back in the 90s yeah bringing
that like pretty hardcore game to life
but now you've got to you got a few DLCs
for X come to gosh ends last gift you
got enter keys children there's more
cosmetic stuff and then you've got
chosen war coming out soon yeah um do
you think you'll like leave XCOM behind
anytime soon obviously you probably
can't go into too much detail but yeah
are you itching to kind of do something
new or is still like something you're
committed to and this is and I get I get
assets and I can answer and honestly
because I can tell you so I've been at
four axis games for 17 years over 17
years it was
my first job out of college I've been
married for 17 years I am a guy when I
like something I like it and I just
don't I'm gifted to be simple enough to
be like it I like it I don't typically
be like or I could do this other thing
I'm more like I like this I will
probably do this for the rest of my will
probably be on this stage and 50 will be
floating because at least five years
from now what weight in 50 I'll be 90 I
think I think I'm younger than him okay
I'll be 90 I'll be making XCOM 27 you
know and I'll be it's great I love it I
mean I really don't I honestly don't see
myself leaving this because because
especially even when you see the other
Studios dipping their toes into tactical
stuff like there's just so much left to
do there is so much left to do and I
like this genre games because this this
is my favorite and this is when I play
and so I play all kinds of games but for
me this is what I always come back to so
you know sometimes you know I'll see
something people are doing I could I get
blown away by it but I really I always
get excited by like what more can I do
in this space yeah what do you think of
the overall state of the strategy like
larger strategy genre now cuz you see so
many things you see fire emblem doing
really well out in 3d s you see if I
said Ubisoft shut off a really weird
quirky combination of two big like
properties yeah but like but you see
other things like outside of that you
see like tactical games you see you know
like his favorite game is Final Fantasy
Tactics that's nowhere to be seen right
but and I still doubt it but surely not
for long right I mean that's what I
think I think like I think everybody's
recognizing surely not for long I mean I
think that especially as we have more
platforms to play on you know strategy
games tactical games games that are
focused around turns that give the
player a little more freedom to play
games like none of us who sit there and
rarely do we just sit there and play
games anymore like I play games and I've
got a stream going and I'm messing
around social media like and so tackle
games any turn-based games they're great
for that and it doesn't mean that that's
all you have to play I think that people
just more open now to being like yeah
that everyone smile I'll play this I'll
have this kind of experience with games
or I'll play this different kind of
games so
I don't think that I'm also dying for
Final Fantasy Tactics to come back
strong it needs to be like a medieval
like you know high fantasy type not that
we're kids we opened a book and we
time-traveled ride still kids see
somebody's been thinking about this yeah
waiting day jump on it and what bugs me
is that I've been telling him since I've
known him that it's my favorite game of
all time and he has never played it play
XCOM 2 and then we can talk right I
can't get it oh I will play Final
Fantasy X but all right so Jake Solomon
when can we play for the chosen August
29th it's out on pc xbox one and ps4
awesome well we really appreciate taking
time out I know you're probably busy
this week no I love I love stopping by
here so thank you guys yeah time to talk
to me thank you so much